>> HERE'S WHAT HAPPENED
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
LAST WEEK...
>> UM, I'M SORRY.
PLEASE DON'T TALK TO ME
LIKE THAT.
>> I AM SCARED TO GET
IN A CONFLICT WITH ALEXANDRIA
BECAUSE SHE COULD WHUP MY BUTT.
>> TWO OF MY BROTHERS DIED.
THAT'S HARD.
AND, LIKE, I WANT TO BE HERE
BUT I'M NOT READY TO BE HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU WANNA MAKE
THE RIGHT DECISION.
>> FOR TODAY'S PHOTO SHOOT,
YOU GUYS WILL BE WORKING
WITH SOME OF THE BUSIEST BEES
IN THE BUSINESS.
(bees buzzing)
>> OOH!
>> WELCOME TO ANOTHER JUDGING.
ONDREI, YOU'RE FIRST.
>> I MUST SAY THAT
I DON'T FEEL RIGHT BEING HERE.
>> SO YOU WANNA GO HOME?
>> I DO.
IF ONDREI DOES NOT HAVE
THE WORST PHOTO,
THERE WILL BE AN ELIMINATION
TONIGHT.
>> I THINK THAT NICOLE
IS PHOTOGRAPHING OLD.
>> AND NICOLE WAS ELIMINATED.
11 GIRLS REMAIN,
BUT ONLY ONE WILL HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH IMG, COVERGIRL,
AND APPEAR ON THE PAGES
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHO DO YOU THINK
WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ON TOP ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
>> ♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
>> YOU WANNA BE ON TOP?
♪ IT'S TIME TO MAKE IT HOT ♪
♪ GET IT UP ♪
♪ YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT WE DON'T STOP ♪
♪ NA, AND WHEN YOU GET IT HOT ♪
♪ NA, YOU GOTTA BE ON TOP ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
♪ ALL THE LADIES ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
WANNA BE ON TOP?
WHOO!
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA NA ♪
♪ NA NA NA NA-NA ♪
♪ ALL, ALL, ALL, ALL ♪
>> WANNA BE ON TOP?
(static hisses)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> OH, MY GOODNESS!
>> OH, YAY!
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I SEE HANNAH'S PICTURE UP
BECAUSE SHE GOT
BEST PICTURE OF THE WEEK.
(record needle scratches)
>> HEY, WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
(suspenseful music plays)
>> AND THERE IS A ROLL
HANGING ON THE WINDOW,
AND IT SAYS, "PULL ME."
>> (screaming)
>> (speaks indistinctly)
>> PULL IT!
>> GO!
>> COME ON!
>> (screaming)
>> WE'RE GETTING MAKEOVERS!
>> MAKEOVERS!
>> (screaming)
>> IT IS A LIST
OF ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
MAKEOVERS.
>> LOOK! THIS COULD BE ME!
>> "SHORT DUTCH BOY."
WHO'S SHORT DUTCH BOY?
>> IT'S EITHER YOU...
>> WE'RE TRYING TO, LIKE,
GUESS WHO'S GETTING WHAT.
>> YOU GUYS!
>> I KNEW THE "MANLY"--
THE "MANLY" IS MINE.
I HAVE A SINKING FEELING
IN MY STOMACH THAT
I'M "MANLY SHORT BROWN SPIKES"
HAIRCUT.
I AM VERY ANDROGYNOUS.
I ENJOY THAT.
IT'S PART OF MY IDENTITY.
BUT AT SOME TIMES,
I DEFINITELY WOULD LIKE
THE OPTION OF BEING FEMININE.
GIVE ME A WEAVE!
GIVE ME EXTENSIONS, TYRA!
DON'T GIVE ME SHORT HAIR.
>> I'M SO FRICKIN' EXCITED!
I'M WONDERING WHAT
I'M GONNA GET.
I FEEL LIKE I'M STILL
WORKING ON MY CONFIDENCE
IN MY PHOTO SHOOTS.
>> HEY, DOMINIQUE, DON'T SWALLOW
INTO YOUR SHOULDERS.
>> LIKE, WHEN YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE
IN THE BACKGROUND
TELLING YOU THIS AND THAT,
WITH THE TYPE OF PERSON
THAT I AM, THE NEGATIVE STUFF
JUST EATS ME UP ALIVE,
AND SO IT BRINGS
MY CONFIDENCE DOWN.
MAYBE THIS NEW LOOK WILL
HELP ME WITHIN MY PHOTO SHOOTS
AND SHOW THAT
I'M NOT JUST A BLANK CANVAS
WITH FRECKLES.
>> WAIT, WHO'S "KINKY RED"?
>>
IWANNA BE RED!
>> I JUST HOPE I'M NOT
THE DUTCH BOY.
I JUST REALLY LIKE MY HAIR,
AND I DON'T REALLY WANT
TO CUT IT.
>> I DON'T WANT BLONDE, THOUGH.
PLEASE DON'T GIVE ME
BLONDE HAIR.
>> I REALLY, REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY,REALLY WANT
THE RED HAIR.
>> WE ALL JUST CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
WHAT TYRA HAS IN STORE FOR US.
>> ♪ OH, OH ♪
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL
AFTER TONIGHT?
>> ANNOYED.
>> YOU'RE ANNOYED?
>> YEAH. I DON'T LIKE BEING...
I KNOW YOU DON'T LIKE IT EITHER,
BEING CALLED, LIKE...
>> NO. UGH.
>> ONE OF THE LAST PEOPLE.
>> THAT WAS, LIKE,
THE WORST FEELING IN THE WORLD.
>> THE WORST FEELING!
SO WE HAD PANEL TODAY.
I WAS THE BOTTOM THREE
WITH DALYA.
>> YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL,
BUT YOU'RE NOT REALLY
OWNING THIS PICTURE.
>> OH, I'M DEFINITELY
COMPETITIVE.
SO IF I DON'T QUITE DO
WHAT I REALLY KNOW I CAN DO,
IT--IT MAKES ME MAD.
SO WE'RE GONNA GET
OUR MAKEOVERS,
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO WORK
A TOTALLY DIFFERENT LOOK.
>> MM-HMM.
>> I'M JUST EXCITED TO SEE
WHAT THEY DO TO US,
SO I'M READY TO BE SURPRISED
TOMORROW.
MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE WILL
BE IN THE BOTTOM THREE.
>> YES. (laughs)
>> OKAY, RIGHT, SO, LIKE,
NOW COUNT--COUNT THE NUMBERS.
ONE, TWO... OKAY.
WE'RE DOWN TWO GIRLS
INSTEAD OF ONE GIRL.
AND TODAY IS MAKEOVER DAY,
WHICH MEANS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A LITTLE MORE DRAMA.
>> WHOO!
>> (laughs) ALL RIGHT,
SO YOU GUYS KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GETTING, RIGHT?
>> NO.
>> UH-HUH.
MONIQUE, WHY--LOOK,
DID YOU SEE MONIQUE'S FACE?
SHE JUST LOOKED AT ME, LIKE,
PETRIFIED.
>> SHE'S SO SCARED.
>> I DO WANT TO WELCOME YOU GUYS
TO THE PRIVÉ SALON,
BECAUSE, LET ME TELL YOU,
I HAVE WORKED
WITH THE MAN OF THE HOUR,
AND HE IS SOTALENTED.
>> THIS MAN HAS DONE
MAJOR STARS.
HE'S DONE MAJOR CAMPAIGNS--
LAURENT D.
OUI. COMMENT ÇA VA? TRES BIEN?
>> ÇA VA TRES BIEN.
>> (speaks French)
>> HI, GIRLS. WELCOME.
>> AND, GIRLS, RIGHT AFTER
YOU GET YOUR TRANSFORMATIONS,
YOU ARE GONNA GO
INTO A PHOTO SHOOT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND WE ALSO HAVE HERE
TROY JENSEN.
HE'S A FELLOW MAKEUP ARTIST
TURNED PHOTOGRAPHER.
AND THE FIRST TIME THAT
TROY EVER HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOOT A CELEBRITY,
IT WAS TYRA BANKS.
TROY, COME ON OUT HERE.
>> HELLO.
>> HI, GIRLS. HOW ARE YOU?
>> HI!
>> I HAVE A VERY HOT SHOOT
PLANNED FOR YOU,
SO I'M VERY EXCITED.
SO LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
>> LET'S GO.
>> OKAY!
>> AAH!
>> WHAT AM I GETTING?
IS IT GOING SHORT?
LAURENT, THE OWNER OF THE SALON,
HE'S LIKE... (French accent)
"ARE YOU READY?
YOU'RE GOING TO
GO SHORT, BLACK WITH A BANG."
(normal voice) HE JUST
GRABS MY HAIR
AND SNIPS, SNIPS, SNIPS,
AND WITHIN THREE CUTS,
MY HAIR WAS ABOUT TO HERE.
RIGHT NOW,
I'M JUST KIND OF PLAIN JANE
AND I BLEND IN WITH EVERYBODY.
AND THEY KNOW WHAT IT TAKES
TO MAKE SOMEONE STAND OUT
AND LOOK LIKE A MODEL,
SO I FULLY TRUST THEM.
>> HERE'S ONE OF 'EM.
>> I'M A SMALL TOWN GIRL
FROM A TRAILER PARK,
AND I LOVE BEING HERE.
IT'S JUST INCREDIBLY BEAUTIFUL,
THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE,
BECAUSE I GET TO MEET
THESE AMAZING PEOPLE
THAT I NEVER EXPECTED TO MEET
IN MY ENTIRE LIFE.
>> (speaks indistinctly)
GOOD LUCK.
>> THANK YOU.
>> TRY BOTH SIDES
SO WE SEE YOUR ANGLES.
>> YES, WORKING THE ANGLE
OF THAT HAIR ALL THE TIME.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> LIKE, I DEFINITELY DON'T
FEEL LIKE MYSELF ANYMORE.
I'M A WHOLE NEW PERSON.
>> (sighs)
I'M NERVOUS.
>> DON'T BE. (chuckles)
>> OOH.
SO I GET IN MY CHAIR,
AND THEY PUT CURLERS IN MY HAIR.
I GUESS I WAS
THE "BIG GURLY & CURLY,"
WHICH I ALREADY AM.
I EXPECTED STRAIGHT HAIR...
>> MM-HMM.
>> JUST BECAUSE I HAVE
CURLY HAIR.
>> MM-HMM.
>> BUT THIS IS FINE WITH ME.
>> NOW YOU REALIZE THAT
ONCE YOU LEAVE THIS CHAIR,
THERE'S A RAZOR BACK THERE.
>> MM-HMM.
>> DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> MNH-MNH.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> OKAY.
>> PSYCH!
(laughs)
>> GORGEOUS.
>> YOU KNOW, I'M HERE
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION.
>> I LOVE HOW CONFIDENT YOU ARE,
JACLYN.
IT'S, LIKE,
THIS IS SUPER AMAZING.
>> WHEN YOU REALLY WANT
SOMETHING AND IT'S YOUR PASSION,
THEN YOU JUST HAVE TO GO FOR IT
AND DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
>> I'M SO HAPPY.
>> I'M GLAD THEY'RE ADDING
AND NOT TAKING AWAY.
(iron hisses)
>> I'M GETTING
FUSION BOND EXTENSIONS
IN MY HAIR.
SO I'M ACTUALLY ADDING HAIR,
NOT CUTTING IT.
I GET MY WAY.
I LOVE MY LIFE.
I ALWAYS GET WHAT I WANT...
USUALLY.
IS IT GOOD?
>> YEAH. I-I LOVE IT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT'S VERY SEXY, BUT THAT'S
YOUR WHOLE THING ANYWAY.
>> RIGHT.
>> YEAH, SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TRY HARD.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOU JUST KINDA JUST WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING.
>> SUCH A PROBLEM TO BE SEXY.
>> ISN'T--ISN'T IT HORRIBLE?
>> YEAH, IT SUCKS.
I'M A LITTLE CURVY.
I DEFINITELY DO HAVE
MORE OF A FIGURE THAN
THE REST OF THE MODELS HERE.
>> BEAUTIFUL.
>> I JUST NEED TO WORK
ON NOT BEING SO SEXY
WITH MY POSES.
>> READY?
>> YES.
WEAVE.
I JUST WANT A WEAVE, TYRA.
JUST GIVE ME LONG HAIR.
DO YOU WANT TO LICK IT?
>> (laughs)
>> I AM GETTING
THE "MANLY, SHORT BROWN SPIKES."
I CAN ALREADY TELL, LIKE,
WHAT'S GOING ON.
MY GENDER IDENTITY IS MUDDLED
WITH A LOT OF MASCULINE,
A LOT OF FEMININE.
I HAVE A HAIRY NECK.
AND THEY THOUGHT
CUTTING MY HAIR SHORT
WILL HIGHLIGHT
MY ANDROGYNOUS FEATURES.
>> YOU WERE HOPING
TO GET A WEAVE?
>> I WANTED
LONG, WAIST-LENGTH HAIR.
BUT BECAUSE I HAVE
A VERY SPECIAL SORT OF FACE...
>> OOH! YES, YOU DO, GIRL.
>> THE MANLY KIND OF FACE...
>> OOH, YES!
(deepens voice) MAYBE MANLY.
>> RELAX AND REALLY GIVE IT
TO MY CAMERA, OKAY?
I THINK THIS LOOK DOES
MAKE ME LOOK MORE EDGY.
IT'S GONNA MAKE ME
WORK A LOT HARDER,
'CAUSE ALL THE ATTENTION
IS NOW ON MY FACE.
I DON'T HAVE HAIR
TO WORK WITH OR PLAY WITH.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> THEY TOUCHED UP MY ROOTS,
AND THEY'RE ADDING
WAVY, LONG HAIR.
AND I LOVE MY HAIR.
I FEEL LIKE SOMETHING'S
GOING WRONG AND I HAVE, LIKE,
A VERY GOOD INTUITION.
THERE'S SOME FLAT PIECES
AND THERE'S
SOME SQUISHED ROUND PIECES.
THEY'RE--I KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO LOOK LIKE.
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
PERFECTLY ROUND,
WE'RE THEY'RE, LIKE, BEADS.
>> WHO DOES THAT?
LIKE, THEY'RE THE HAIRDRESSER,
NOT YOU.
LIKE, SHE THINKS THAT
SHE KNOWS EVERYTHING.
WAS I COMPLAINING
WHEN THEY CHOPPED OFF MY HAIR?
NO.
>> YOU'LL BE FINE.
>> I DON'T LIKE FAKE HAIR.
>> THEY'LL TAKE CARE OF YOU.
>> I WANT IT TO BE LOOKING OKAY
IF IT IS.
>> IT'LL BE BEAUTIFUL.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT, OKAY?
>> YOU PROMISE?
>> I PROMISE. IT WILL BE FINE.
WE'RE GONNA TAKE CARE OF YOU.
>> EVEN THE ONES THAT ARE
ALREADY DONE?
>> WE WILL TAKE CARE OF IT.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT, OKAY?
>> ALEXANDRIA--
THE WAY SHE HANDLED HERSELF
AND TREATED THE PEOPLE
IN THE SALON,
MADE ME JUST WANT TO GO
YELL AT HER FOR IT,
BECAUSE SHE JUST THINKS
SHE RUNS EVERYTHING.
>> (exhales deeply)
THIS IS SO INTENSE.
>> YOU STILL HAVE A BANG.
>> IT WAS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
>> AFTER I GOT HELP
WITH MY HAIR,
I ABSOLUTELY FEEL
LIKE I'M ON TRACK.
LOVE IT.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> I NEED IT DONE MY WAY.
MY WAY'S THE RIGHT WAY
BECAUSE IT'S A COMPETITION.
>> GIVE ME, LIKE, A WICKED EYE.
YEAH, LIKE THAT, EXACTLY.
>> AND IF I DON'T FEEL CONFIDENT
AND IF YOU'RE SCREWING
WITH THAT CONFIDENCE,
THEN YOU'RE SCREWING WITH ME.
>> HOO! ALL RIGHT, I'M READY.
I'M READY.
WHENEVER Y'ALL READY, I'M READY.
I'M GETTING THIS KINKY RED
WITH THE MATCHING EYEBROWS.
>> EEK!
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
>> (crying) I WAS THINKING
I WAS GONNA LIKE IT,
AND I DON'T LIKE IT.
>> YOU NEED TO STOP CONTROLLING.
BEING A TOP MODEL
IN THIS BUSINESS IS
NOT ABOUT BEING SAFE.
YOU WANT TO, LIKE,
DO SOMETHING.
YOU WANT TO POP.
>> I'M EXCITED, YET SCARED.
>> THIS IS SO OUT OF MY ELEMENT,
BUT I THINK THAT THE COLOR
ACTUALLY MAKES ME STAND OUT,
SO I FEEL LIKE
I LOOK MORE LIKE A MODEL NOW.
>> NOW ARE YOU HAPPY?
>> YES.
>> MISS MOUTH. I WANNA, LIKE...
MAYBE YOU SHOULD TRUST IN THOSE
WHO KNOW THAT THEY'RE DOING.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> YOU KNOW, THE THING
ABOUT BEING A MODEL IS
YOU HAVE TO STAND OUT
AND BE UNIQUE AND BE YOU.
AND SO I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
BRINGING A MORE UNIQUE ME.
>> ALL I KNOW IS
I'M GETTING A WEAVE
OF SOME BLONDE, CURLY SOMETHING.
YOU KNOW,
I'VE NEVER REALLY HAD BIG HAIR,
AND MY HAIR LIKES TO LAY FLAT
AND STRAIGHT.
SO IT'LL BE NEW,
BUT, UH, I THINK I CAN WORK IT.
>> OOH.
SO, MOLLY, WE--WE BROUGHT IN
AN OUTSIDE WEAVE SPECIALIST,
BECAUSE TO THIS KIND OF WEAVE
ON THIS KIND OF HAIR
WILL BE DIFFICULT FOR ANYBODY.
SO WE'LL HAVE TO SEE IF,
MM, HOW THIS ALL TURNS OUT.
SO WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?
I'M--I'M LOOKING
AT TRACKS OF HAIR.
I'M LOOKING AT BASKET WEAVE.
>> HAIR IS VERY SLIPPERY.
IT'S VERY FINE.
AND WE DECIDED THE NET
WOULD ACTUALLY BE TOO MUCH,
SO WE CREATED OUR OWN NET.
>> SO YOU'RE GONNA DO IT
IN A CIRCLE.
OKAY.
>> HAVE A SEAT, MY DEAR.
>> SIT DOWN, BABY.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> I AM REALIZING THAT THIS IS
KIND OF LOOKING A LITTLE WEIRD.
IT WAS JUST NOT LOOKING LIKE
WHAT A WEAVE SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE THE ONE GIRL
WHO GETS THE CRAZY HAIRSTYLE
THAT LOOKS HORRIBLE.
>> THIS LADY--
SHE TOTALLY BUTCHERED MY HAIR.
IT LOOKS ABSOLUTELY HORRENDOUS.
NO ONE WAS HAPPY WITH IT.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT IT WAS
RIDICULOUS-LOOKING.
>> JUST IT'S COMING
FROM MY SALON.
THOSE EXTENSIONS--WHAT IS THAT?
>> OOH.
>> TWISTED SISTER?
>> I'M TRYING TO THINK
OF HOW WE COULD STYLE THIS
SOME SORT OF WAY FOR THE PICTURE
AND THEN CORRECT IT AFTER.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND HE'S GONNA CREATE
THAT MAGIC, DARLING.
WHEW!
>> I AM GETTING
SUPER LONG, BLACK,
GORGEOUS, STRAIGHT HAIR.
I FEEL LIKE THE LITTLE MERMAID.
FOR THE PAST SIX YEARS
OF MY LIFE,
I'VE REALLY STARTED
TO GET INTO MODELING,
BUT I NEED SOMETHING
TO PROPEL ME.
>> FEEL THE LENGTH OF THAT HAIR.
>> MAYBE THERE'S
AN INTIMIDATION FACTOR TO ME.
>> GORGEOUS.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD BE LOOKING OUT FOR ME
IN THIS COMPETITION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I'M GETTING
THE WILD, CRAZY, CRIMPED HAIR.
I HAVE NEVER HAD THIS MUCH HAIR
IN MY LIFE.
I THOUGHT I HAD
A LOT OF HAIR NATURALLY.
>> READY?
>> I LOVE MY MAKEOVER.
IT'S WILD AND CRAZY,
BUT SO AM I,
SO I THINK IT FITS
MY PERSONALITY.
BIGGER IS BETTER, RIGHT?
I'M DEFINITELY READY
TO BE A COVERGIRL.
>> I'VE NEVER HAD, LIKE,
A NET SEWN TO MY HEAD BEFORE.
HOW MY PARENTS RAISED ME,
IT WAS KIND OF, LIKE,
YOU NEED TO BE RESERVED
WITH YOUR BODY.
IT'S, LIKE, YOUR TEMPLE.
YOU JUST WANT TO BE SUBTLE
WITH YOUR POSING.
>> STAY TALL. BEAUTIFUL.
>> I DO FEEL LIKE THIS IS GONNA
HELP ME LOOK MORE MODEL-ESQUE.
>> THAT LOOKED REALLY PRETTY.
>> BECAUSE BEFORE--
THAT PONYTAIL NEEDED SOME HELP.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I GOT MY HIGHLIGHTS
AND I ALSO GOT MY EYEBROWS
LIGHTENED, WHICH I REALLY LIKE
CAUSE IT MAKES MY EYES POP
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
I FEEL LIKE I COULD BE
IN A HAIR AD.
I LOVE IT.
I JUST FELT, LIKE,
A LITTLE BIT MORE, LIKE,
LUSCIOUS AND SEXY,
WHICH BEFORE I DIDN'T HAVE,
AND I THINK THAT'S GONNA HELP
MY CONFIDENCE A LOT
IN THE COMPETITION.
>> OHH.
LAURENT, THE OWNER--
HE'S AWESOME, AND HE WAS TRYING
TO MAKE IT LOOK
SOMEWHAT PRESENTABLE
FOR A PICTURE.
>> NOW YOU WORK YOUR MAGIC.
>> I CAN WORK THIS.
>> I JUST WANT YOU
TO UNDERSTAND ONE THING.
I MEAN, THIS IS
REALLY TYRA'S VISION.
>> YEAH.
>> I MEAN, SHE REALLY WANTED
YOU TO HAVE THIS LOOK.
>> I TOTALLY GET IT.
>> AND YOU HAVE TO KINDA
TREAT TYRA AS THE CLIENT.
CAN YOU PROVE TO THE CLIENT
THAT YOU CAN OWN THAT LOOK?
>> OKAY, I GOTTA SHOOT THIS,
GUYS.
AND I THINK WITH THIS HAIR, TOO,
YOU CAN WORK THE HANDS UP.
DON'T HOLD ON TO IT,
BUT WORK THE HANDS IN IT
LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW?
>> LOVE THE IDEA
OF THE HUGE, BLONDE HAIR,
BUT, UM, IT LOOKS HORRIBLE,
SO I'M NOT HAPPY WITH IT
WHATSOEVER.
>> MOLLY, SIT OVER HERE.
>> I'M NOT... HAPPY.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE AN...
I'M SORRY, BUT I'M PISSED OFF.
MY HAIR IS DISGUSTING.
MY WHOLE HEAD HURTS.
MY ASS HURTS.
I SAT IN A... CHAIR
FOR SIX... HOURS.
SHE STABBED ME IN THE HEAD
WITH NEEDLES ALL DAY.
>> I KNOW. MY GIRL...
BUT I STOOD UP.
>> EVERYONE KNEW IT.
>> BUT YOU SHOULD HAVE BEEN
LIKE, "STOP DOING MY HAIR."
MOLLY SAT THERE
AND KINDA JUST LET IT HAPPEN.
(laughs)
OH, I CAN'T EVEN
STOP LAUGHING ABOUT IT.
>> BUT, NO, MOLLY,
IT'S REALLY PRETTY.
IT'S JUST--
>> IT'S PRETTY
IF YOU COULDN'T SEE
MYHAIR
WHERE IT MEETS THE TRACKS
BRAIDED INTO MY SCALP.
>> I FELT BAD FOR MOLLY
JUST BECAUSE IT WAS
THAT HORRIBLE,
BUT SHE'S ONE
OF MY TOP COMPETITORS.
BUT IF SHE LETS
THIS HAIR RUIN HER,
THEN IT'S KIND OF, LIKE,
ONE LESS PERSON
I HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> (sighs)
♪♪♪♪♪
>> I FEEL LIKE I NEED
A CUP OF COFFEE OR SOMETHING.
>> I'M JUST SURPRISED
THAT I EVEN GOT MY HAIR,
UM, COLORED.
LIKE, FOR REAL.
>> IT'S SEXY.
>> NOW THAT I HAVE
MY FABULOUS RED, KINKY HAIR,
I'M STARTING TO REALIZE, LIKE,
OH, OKAY, IT'S NOT TOO BAD.
I-I WAS ALREADY UNIQUE
WITH THE FRECKLES,
BUT THIS IS MORE.
AND IT MIGHT BE WHAT I NEEDED.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> TYRA MAIL!
>> OH! TYRA MAIL!
>> AAH!
AAH!
>> "TOMORROW YOU'LL LEARN
ALL ABOUT PHOTOSYNTHESIS.
LOVE, TYRA."
>> I THINK WE'RE GONNA
BE DRESSED IN FLOWERS.
I'M GONNA BE A SKUNKWEED.
>> WHAT IF OUR CLOTHES
ARE MADE OUT OF PLANTS?
>> OF COURSE, I AM JUST TERRIBLE
AT GUESSING THE TYRA MAIL.
I NEVER KNOW
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING.
>> (sighs)
I'M INCREDIBLY SAD
AND DISAPPOINTED.
YOU KNOW, LONG HAIR,
YOU CAN KINDA, LIKE,
HIDE BEHIND IT
OR USE IT AS AN ACCESSORY
OR WHATEVER.
(sniffles) AND IT'S COOL
'CAUSE IT'S MAKING ME
WORK HARDER,
BUT IT'S ALSO GIVING ME, LIKE,
A HUGE AMOUNT OF STRESS,
LIKE, UGH.
I SEE THESE GIRLS,
AND IT'S HARD
NOT TO FEEL INTIMIDATED
BY HOW BEAUTIFUL THEY ARE,
BUT HOW WELL THEY PHOTOGRAPH.
I FEEL LIKE DIRTY SMÉAGOL
IN THE CORNER,
LIKE TRYING TO NOT BE JEALOUS.
>> WE'RE AT A FARM.
>> ♪ I'M SO EXCITED ♪
>> SO WE ARRIVE AT THE RANCH.
IT WAS SO BEAUTIFUL,
AND OF COURSE,
WE'RE WORKING WITH PLANTS
OR DOING SOMETHING WITH PLANTS.
>> SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> LOOKING ALL LIKE MODELS.
OWNING...
>> TOTALLY.
>> OWNING YOUR NEW LOOKS.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU GUYS,
YOU ARE IN THE PRESENCE
OF ROYALTY THIS MORNING.
YES, WE HAVE WORLD-RENOWNED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
PAMELA HANSON.
SHE HAS SHOT
FOR AMERICAN "VOGUE,"
ITALIAN "VOGUE."
WHICH "VOGUE"
HAVEN'T YOU SHOT FOR?
I MEAN, TRULY, YOU KNOW,
A CREATIVE VISIONARY.
WE--I'M SURE YOU GUYS
KNOW WHO THIS IS--
LORI GOLDSTEIN, FASHION STYLIST
WHO COLLABORATES WITH ALL
OF THE AMAZING PHOTOGRAPHERS
AND PUTS TOGETHER LOOKS.
>> YAY! FAMOUS PEOPLE
WHO I WILL EVENTUALLY
WORK WITH IN THE FUTURE.
AWESOME.
>> SO THIS IS YOUR DREAM TEAM,
AND IT'S ALL ABOUT
COUTURE TODAY.
>> YAY!
>> IT KINDA DOESN'T GET
ANY BETTER THAN THAT.
IT'S, LIKE, UNREAL.
MODELS WHO ARE WORKING EVERYDAY
DON'T GET TO DO
THIS KIND OF STUFF.
I MEAN, IT'S COUTURE.
>> NOW, OF COURSE,
THERE'S GONNA BE
ANOTHER LITTLE LAYER
TO THIS SHOOT
THAT MAKES IT A LITTLE TRICKIER.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE POSING
IN GROUPS.
IN THE WORLD OF HIGH FASHION,
ALL OF THE, YOU KNOW, DESIGNERS
ARE LOOKING TO SEE,
"WHICH COULD BE
MY NEXT CAMPAIGN GIRL?"
SO YOU'RE REALLY
ALWAYS COMPETING WITH
THAT GIRL IN THE PHOTOGRAPH.
SO YOU HAVE TO KEEP THAT
IN MIND TODAY.
NOW LET'S GET YOU GUYS GOING.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> IT'S AWESOME
'CAUSE IT'S ALL COUTURE,
AND I SEE MY NAME ON THE RACK
NEXT TO
THIS CAROLINA HERRERA GOWN,
AND I'M JUST DROOLING.
>> AND THIS IS PERFECT ON YOU.
>> LORI AND PAMELA
JUST GET RIGHT TO IT.
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANT FOR THE SHOOT.
>> LOOK, PAMMY.
A LITTLE JOHN GALLIANO
NEVER HURT ANYBODY.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> (giggles)
>> CAN YOU GUYS BELIEVE
HOW LUCKY YOU ARE
TO WEAR THESE CLOTHES?
>> THEY KNOW WHAT THE LOOK IS,
WHAT THE IDEA IS,
WHAT THE CONCEPT IS,
AND IT'S NO WONDER
THAT THEY'RE SO AMAZING
AT THEIR JOBS.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> SO HAD YOU MODELED
BEFORE THIS?
>> YES, MA'AM.
THIS ISN'T MY FIRST RODEO.
>> (laughs)
>> MAYBE MAKE YOUR HAIR
JUST BIGGER THIS WAY.
>> WORK YOUR MAGIC ON THIS MESS.
I'M DEFINITELY FEELING
A LITTLE BEATEN DOWN
FROM MY HAIRSTYLE,
BUT I'M HOPING THE HAIR TEAM,
YOU KNOW, CAN MAKE IT LOOK GOOD
FOR A PHOTO.
>> MOLLY, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOUR HAIR.
>> IT'S SO MUCH BETTER.
>> YOU OWE ME DINNER.
>> HA!
>> THIS WILL BE FUN.
(laughs)
>> I'M SHOOTING WITH KASIA,
AND I'M TOTALLY EXCITED
ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE BOTH BLONDE HAIR,
BLUE EYES,
BUT OUR PERSONALITIES
ARE PRETTY DIFFERENT.
KASIA IS MORE GIRLIE,
AND, UM, I DEFINITELY HAVE
MORE OF AN ANGRY STREAK TO ME
THAN SHE DOES.
>> OKAY, LET'S GO.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> THAT'S NICE, MOLLY.
KASIA, BRING YOUR CHIN DOWN.
JUST BE KIND OF, YEAH.
JUST BE LOOSE, KAS.
>> THE PHOTO STARTED OFF
A LITTLE AWKWARD,
LIKE THEY COULDN'T FIND A WAY
TO MAKE THOSE TWO DRESSES
WORK TOGETHER.
AND CAN YOU TURN
AND REACH WITH THAT ARM
OVER TO MOLLY ALMOST?
>> THERE YOU GO.
(camera shutter clicks)
>> GOOD, KASIA.
SHAPE LOOKS GREAT.
>> LOOK OFF CAMERA.
(gasps) WHO'S THAT OVER THERE?
>> I LIKE YOUR BODY LANGUAGE,
MOLLY.
IT'S GOOD.
>> RIGHT NOW,
MOLLY HAS DEFINITELY OVERCOME
HER MAKEOVER ORDEAL.
SHE REALLY DID
KIND OF DOMINATE THE PHOTO.
>> BEAUTIFUL, BOTH OF YOU.
THAT'S AMAZING.
>> YES, YES.
WE SO HAVE THIS ONE, FOR SURE.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK?
ALL RIGHT, THANKS, GUYS.
>> DOES THAT HURT RIGHT THERE?
>> IT'S OKAY, THOUGH.
>> YOU'RE
SUPER, SUPER SENSITIVE.
>> WELL...
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
DON'T--WATCH OUT,
BECAUSE IF THAT BREAKS,
WE GOT A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
(mouths word)
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE'S ALWAYS BITCHIN'.
(imitates Alexandria)
"OH, MY GOD! MY HAIR!"
>> I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
LET'S NOT TOUCH YOUR HEAD
TOO MUCH
SO YOU DON'T GET CRANKY.
>> I'M NOT CRANKY.
>> (normal voice) SHE, LIKE,
FEELS LIKE SHE HAS TO BE
THE CENTER OF ATTENTION.
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> HER LIP IS SWELLING UP
FOR SOME REASON.
>> I WAS STRESSED OUT,
AND I HAD A PIMPLE ON MY LIP.
I DO NOT WANT
TO HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
DURING THIS COUTURE SHOOT.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
FEEL ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
>> DOES IT HURT?
LET ME SEE.
>> NO. (chuckles)
>> I'M JUST LIKE,
YOU'RE SUCH A BITCH.
DON'T BE RUDE TO ME
RIGHT WHEN WE'RE ABOUT
TO SHOOT TOGETHER,
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA KILL
THE CHEMISTRY.
>> I DON'T EVEN WANNA THINK
ABOUT MY LIP RIGHT NOW.
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE GOT A LITTLE CRANKY
AND A LITTLE FIDGETY.
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS REALLY HARD WORK.
SHE'S GOTTA LEARN
TO REALLY RELAX.
>> ALL RIGHT, YOU GUYS.
MONIQUE, WORK ON YOUR EXPRESSION
A LITTLE MORE, DARLING.
>> WHAT WE SEE ON YOUR FACE IS
THAT YOU'RE FEELING AWKWARD.
>> THINK "DOE-EYED," LIKE THIS.
>> OKAY.
>> BIG EYE,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
JUST DOE-Y. YOU'RE A BIG DOE.
>> DO YOU FEEL PRETTY IN THIS?
I KNOW IT'S AWKWARD
BECAUSE YOU'RE STANDING
ON BRANCHES.
>> MONIQUE--WHEN SHE JUST
DOESN'T LIKE SOMETHING,
SHE POUTS. POOH-POOH.
THIS SHOULD BE A FANTASY.
THIS SHOULD FEEL--
>> YEAH, MAKE IT KINDA PLAYFUL,
LIKE...
>> YEAH.
>> "OH, MY GOD.
WHAT DID WE FIND?"
>> AT THIS POINT,
I'M A LITTLE PISSED OFF
BECAUSE OF ALEXANDRIA
SNAPPING ON ME.
AND THEN HEARING JAY'S CRITICISM
REALLY FRUSTRATES ME AT TIMES.
I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
>> DON'T LOOK TOO MEAN THERE,
MONIQUE.
THAT'S NICE.
>> I THINK I WAS
OUTSHINING MONIQUE.
I-I KINDA STOOD IN FRONT OF HER.
YOU KNOW, I PUT HER
IN THE BACKGROUND.
I DON'T STOP
AND I KNOW WHAT I WANT,
SO IF YOU'RE IN MY WAY,
YOU BETTER KEEP UP.
>> I THINK WE HAVE THIS.
AWESOME.
>> COOL.
>> THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU?
>> YEAH, I'M GOOD.
>> I'M POSITIVE
THAT I GOT A GOOD SHOT.
WELL, I HOPE. I PRAY.
((bell dings)
>> SPIKE.
>> YEAH.
>> REALLY?
I CAN'T GET A WIG OR SOMETHIN'?
LIKE...
DON'T TRY AND OVERSHINE.
WHEN I FIND OUT
THAT I'M POSING WITH MIKAELA,
I'M LIKE, SCORE!
>> OKAY. COME ON.
OH, MIKAELA,
LET ME SEE YOUR FACE.
>> ALWAYS REMEMBER THAT CAMERA,
'CAUSE YOUR EYES ARE, LIKE,
OFF AND CLOSED
IN A LOT OF PICTURES.
>> I END UP BEING PAIRED
WITH SARA, AND I'M ACTUALLY
VERY HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
I WANT TO MAKE THIS SHOT
THE BEST.
>> JUST STANDING LIKE THAT,
YOU LOOK LIKE ROBOTS.
NANU. NANU. AND, UH...
>> THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH ONE ANOTHER--
THAT'S THE PROBLEM--AT ALL.
>> NO.
THEY JUST WEREN'T GETTING
WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO,
AND IT WAS KIND OF THE BLIND
LEADING THE BLIND.
>> WHOA.
>> OH, IT WAS HARD.
>> IT WAS HARD.
>> THERE. YOU CAN LOOK DOWN
IF YOU NEED TO LOOK
WHERE YOU'RE GOING. OKAY, STOP.
>> HEY, SARA, STOP ANALYZING.
I CAN SEE IT IN YOUR FACE.
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH SARA
BECAUSE SHE DEFINITELY
HAS POTENTIAL.
HER LOOK IS REALLY DIFFERENT,
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE MAKEOVER,
BUT I DON'T THINK SHE BELIEVES
IN HERSELF ENOUGH TO DO IT.
>> COME TOWARDS ME.
>> OH, MY GOSH. THAT--
>> THESE ARE GREAT.
DON'T GET STIFF.
LOOK, YOU'RE WALKING, YEAH.
WHOA!
(chuckles)
DO WE HAVE IT?
ALL RIGHT. NEXT.
YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE TO
HOLD HANDS.
>> TALK TO EACH OTHER.
>> (speaks French)
>> OH! THE WIND!
>> ARE YOU THINKING OF SOMETHING
THAT REALLY MAKES YOU GIGGLE
OR ARE YOU JUST TRYING
TO FORCE THAT GIGGLE RIGHT NOW?
>> FORCING IT.
>> YEAH, I COULD TELL.
>> YEAH, THINK OF--
>> IF YOU REALLY THINK
OF SOMETHING
THAT MAKES YOU LAUGH...
>> BRITTANI,
THAT'S A LITTLE CONTRIVED.
RELAX YOUR MOUTH.
THAT LOOKS HORRIBLE.
>> IT'S REALLY HARD TO PORTRAY
SOMETHING WHEN IT'S NOT REAL,
AND I WAS TRYING TO GET
TO A PLACE WHERE I WAS,
LIKE, LAUGHING...
(sniffles) AND, LIKE,
THAT JUST MADE ME UPSET
BECAUSE I WAS DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF.
>> OKAY, IT'S NOW OR NEVER.
NICE.
>> I LOVE THE WAY THE TWO OF YOU
ARE FOLDING INTO
ONE ANOTHER NOW.
>> I THINK WE PROBABLY HAVE IT.
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> IT WAS NICE WORKING WITH YOU.
>> YOU ARE ADORABLE.
>> I'M STILL WORKING
ON MY CONFIDENCE
IN MY PHOTO SHOOTS.
UM, IT DOESN'T COME EASY AT ALL.
AFTER GETTING, LIKE,
THIS--THIS NEW LOOK,
LIKE, I'M THINKING, LIKE,
THIS IS A BRAND-NEW START
FOR ME.
I CAN REALLY SHOW THEM
THAT I HAVE IT.
>> SO WE'RE GONNA DO
A TRIPLE HERE.
JACLYN, STAND TALL, DARLING.
>> JACLYN, REMEMBER,
WE'RE NOT PLAYING FOOTBALL.
>> THAT'S CUTE. I LIKE THAT.
AH, DOMINIQUE, GET IN THERE.
>> THE ONLY PROBLEM
WITH THE 3-SHOT WAS
IT REALLY JUST IS A 2-SHOT.
IF I WERE TO PRINT THAT PHOTO,
I WOULD JUST CROP DOMINIQUE OUT.
DOMINIQUE, I'M NOT GONNA LIE,
THESE TWO ARE HAVING A MOMENT.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING
IN YOUR HEAD, THOUGH?
>> HONESTLY,
I DON'T HAVE NO THOUGHTS.
>> BUT THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> DO YOU KNOW
WHAT THE WORST THING A MODEL
COULD NOT HAVE IS INSPIRATION.
>> (crying) I JUST FEEL LIKE
I'M GIVING MY ALL,
BUT JAY DON'T SEE IT.
>> LOOK AT ME.
DON'T YOU LOSE IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO ANYMORE.
ACCORDING TO JAY,
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
THAT I'M INSPIRED BY.
I'M INSPIRED BY A LOT OF STUFF.
LIKE...
>> WANNA STAY TALL AND GORGEOUS.
THAT'S ACTUALLY SO BEAUTIFUL.
>> BEING A MODEL IS A JOB...
>> YEAH.
>> AND IT'S REALLY HARD.
IT'S LIKE BEING IN THE MUD
IN A HEEL.
YOU KNOW WHAT? FIGURE IT OUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT SEPARATES
YOUR LINDAS AND YOUR CHRISTYS
AND YOUR SHALOMS...
>> GISELE.
>> AND YOUR AMBERS
AND YOUR GISELES.
>> THOSE TOP GIRLS ARE
AWARE OF EVERYTHING.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, GUYS.
YOU WERE GREAT.
>> THAT'S A WRAP, EVERYBODY,
FOR SURE.
>> (cheering)
>> YEAH.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> (screaming)
>> "TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY 10 WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPE OF BECOMING..."
>> "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"!
>> I AM ALWAYS NERVOUS
ABOUT PANEL.
I SHAKE LIKE
A LITTLE HOUSEBROKEN CHIHUAHUA,
LIKE... (hisses)
>> WHAT KIND OF FEEDBACK
DID YOU GET?
>> HE'S LIKE, "YOU NEED
TO JUST STOP THINKING."
AND I WAS LIKE...
>> OKAY.
>> I FEEL LIKE
I'M NOT GOING HOME,
BUT I WILL GET
A STERN TONGUE-LASHING,
BUT MAYBE JUST ME SAYING THAT
WILL JINX ME, AND I'LL GO HOME.
I REALLY HOPE I DON'T.
I WANT TO STAY HERE
AND KEEP IMPROVING.
>> I'M FRUSTRATED
THAT WE DIDN'T GET, LIKE,
"OH, YEAH, AWESOME," LIKE...
>> WE DID.
WE'RE GONNA BE FINE.
>> I'M NOT REALLY SURE
HOW THE PICTURES TURNED OUT.
>> EVERY HAIRSTYLIST
WHO LOOKS AT IT SAYS,
"WHAT THE..."
>> (laughs)
>> I'M JUST TRYING TO STAY OUT
OF ALEXANDRIA'S, LIKE, WARPATH,
BECAUSE SHE IS SO DRAMATIC
ABOUT EVERYTHING.
I JUST WANT TO BE LIKE,
PLEASE STOP TALKING TO ME.
>> WHEN HE CAME UP TO US
AND WAS LIKE,
"DO YOU GUYS FEEL BEAUTIFUL?"
>> YEAH.
>> I'M LIKE, Y...
>> I'M IN VINTAGE... CHANEL
RIGHT NOW. DUH.
>> (whispers) I'M SO SCARED
OF HER.
>> (sighs)
>> ALEXANDRIA--
SHE THINKS SHE RUNS EVERYONE.
SHE THINKS SHE CAN TELL
EVERYONE WHAT TO DO,
AND I DON'T WANT TO SOUND
LIKE A MEAN, RUDE PERSON,
BUT THERE COMES A POINT
WHERE YOU START
TO CROSS THE LINE.
IT'S JUST ALL ABOUT, LIKE,
WHO YOU KNOW AND...
>> YEAH.
AND PEOPLE REMEMBER YOU.
>> I FEEL LIKE SOME OF THE GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED BY ME,
IN THE HOUSE.
I'M VERY, VERY STRONG,
SO IF THEY FEEL INTIMIDATED,
AMEN.
IT'S A COMPETITION. BE SCARED.
I COULD BE SCARY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> HOW ARE YOU?
(gasps)
THE STYLING YOU DID...
>> YEAH.
>> OOH! IT WAS AMAZING.
>> MM. HOW ARE YOU, ANGEL?
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU SMELL GOOD, TOO.
>> I DO?
>> YES.
>> NO FUNK?
>> NO FUNK.
>> I... (laughs)
>> I'M NOT FUNKY.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> WELL, HELLO, LADIES.
>> HELLO.
>> HOW ARE WE DOING?
>> GOOD.
>> ARE WE READY
FOR ANOTHER ELIMINATION?
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHTY, LADIES.
YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST--MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER,
ANDRÉ LEON TALLEY, ONE OF
THEMOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE
IN ALL OF THE HISTORY
OF FASHION,
AND YOU WORKED
WITH LORI GOLDSTEIN.
LORI HAS STYLED
OVER 60 COVERS
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE,"
AND SHE WAS
A CONTRIBUTING EDITOR
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE"
AND "ALLURE" MAGAZINES. MM-HMM.
YOU KNOW OUR PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH IMG MODELS,
ONE OF THETOP
MODEL MANAGEMENT COMPANIES
IN THE ENTIRE WORLD,
A SPREAD IN ITALIAN "VOGUE,"
AND A COVER
IN THE BEAUTY VERSION
OF ITALIAN "VOGUE"
CALLED "BEAUTY IN VOGUE,"
AS WELL AS A SPREAD
IN THAT MAGAZINE AS WELL,
AND YOU GET FEATURED
ON "VOGUE ITALIA'S" WEB SITE
vogue.it,
AND OF COURSE,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
SHALL WE BEGIN?
SO THE GIRLS SHOT
IN GROUPS THIS WEEK.
THE CHALLENGE WAS
TO WORK TOGETHER,
BUT TO STAND OUT MORE...
>> (laughing)
>> THAN THE OTHER GIRL
IN YOUR PHOTO.
>> AS YOU WOULD KNOW HOW TO DO.
(laughs)
>> YOU'RE TRYING TO SAY
I'M AN UPSTAGER?
THE FIRST GROUP
ON THE CHOPPING BLOCK IS
MONIQUE AND ALEXANDRIA.
HELLO.
>> HI.
>> HELLO.
>> HOW WAS IT WORKING TOGETHER?
>> WE DID WELL.
>> YOU DID WELL?
>> MM-HMM.
>> THERE'S SO MANY MODELS
THAT WHEN THEY GET
TO A CERTAIN LEVEL, THEY'RE
LIKE, "I DON'T DO DOUBLES.
I DON'T DO DOUBLES."
I NEVER SAID NO TO A DOUBLE.
I JUST SAID, "BACK UP, BITCH."
ARE WE READY FOR OUR BEST SHOT?
>> YEAH.
>> HERE IT IS.
>> STUNNING.
>> AND YOU BOTH LOOK GREAT.
AND I DON'T THINK
ONE UPSTAGES THE OTHER.
>> MONIQUE, THE LOOK
IN YOUR EYE, LOOKING OFF--
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT,
BUT THERE'S PERSONALITY THERE.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS LOOKING FOR.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS MISSING BEFORE
FROM YOU,
BUT I SEE A LITTLE TWINKLE.
AND, ALEXANDRIA,
OUT OF THE TWO,
I RADIATE TOWARDS YOU.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S QUITE POSED,
IT WORKS FOR ME.
>> ALEXANDRIA NAILED IT
IN EVERY SHOT.
WHEN YOU WEREN'T ON CAMERA,
YOU KNOW, YOU COULD SEE
YOU KIND OF GETTING CRANKY
AND THAT'S REALLY SOMETHING
IN THE BUSINESS
THAT PHOTOGRAPHERS WILL LOOK AT
AND--AND HAVE NO TIME FOR.
>> I MEAN,
I THINK IT WORKS IN THE PICTURE.
BUT--BUT OBVIOUSLY,
YOU WERE BEING A DIVA.
AND OBVIOUSLY AT THIS POINT,
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO BE.
>> RIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OKAY, NEXT GROUP--
BRITTANI AND HANNAH.
>> HELLO.
>> BRITTANI, I HAVE
NEVER ASSIGNED A GIRL
THIS MAKEOVER EVER,
AND I'M VERY PROUD.
YOU LOOK AMAZING.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU GUYS READY
TO SEE YOUR BEST DUO?
>> YES.
>> HERE IT IS!
>> GORGEOUS.
THIS WHOLE SHOT WORKS
IN SO MANY WAYS.
HANNAH,
I LOVE THE BODY LANGUAGE.
I LOVE THE SORT OF BROKEN BODY.
UM, YOU KNOW, THIS, FOR ME,
IS YOUR FIRST TRUE FASHION SHOT.
>> BOTH OF YOU, TO ME,
CAPTIVATE HIGH COUTURE HERE.
BRITTANI, YOU'RE GIVING ME
TOTAL HIGH, HIGH, HIGH,
GLOSSYGLAMOUR.
WITH THAT HAIRCUT,
YOU CAN GO RIGHT OVER
TO STEVEN MEISEL
AND DO A WHOLE SPREAD.
I'M BLOWN AWAY
BY THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
>> LORI, THE--THE TOUGH GLOVES
WITH THE--WITH THIS COUTURE,
LIKE, CHIFFON DRESS,
IT'S CRAZY. IT'S AMAZING.
>> IT'S A CAROLINA HERRERA GOWN.
>> IT'S AMAZING, YEAH.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL WALTZ.
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING TOGETHER.
IT MAKES ME VERY HAPPY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
OKAY,
DALYA, JACLYN, AND DOMINIQUE.
>> GORGEOUS AGAIN.
WOW. MY GOODNESS ME.
VERY INTERESTING.
IT HAS A SLIGHTLY
"ALICE IN WONDERLAND-ESQUE"
ELEMENT GOING ON HERE.
DALYA, I-I LOVE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING IN THIS PICTURE--
THE HAND UP TO THE FACE,
LITTLE EXPRESSION.
JACLYN, ETHEREAL, FEMININE,
VERY KIND OF SOUTHERN BELLE
THROWN IN THERE.
YOU HAVEN'T LOST IT.
>> FOR ME, I HOPE
THAT YOU HAVE THE RANGE,
BECAUSE THIS WAS
REALLY YOUR MOMENT
AND THIS IS YOU.
>> I'VE GOTTA SAY, DOMINIQUE,
IT'S UNUSUAL.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T NECESSARILY
FIT IN WITH THE OTHER TWO.
>> DOMINIQUE,
I KNOW THAT THE STRUGGLE
THAT WAS HAPPENING WITH YOU.
YOU FELT LOST.
I FELT LIKE
YOU FELT LIKE AN OUTSIDER.
AND I COULD SEE YOU
LOSING YOURSELF.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
THIS SHRINKING VIOLET.
>> DOMINIQUE, WHAT HAPPENED?
'CAUSE IN YOUR FILM,
IT LOOKED LIKE YOUR MIND,
YOUR SPIRIT WAS GONE.
>> HONESTLY,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WAS.
JAY ASKED ME.
HE SAID, "DOMINIQUE, WHAT IS IT
THAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT?"
AND ON THE SPOT I WAS LIKE,
"I DON'T HAVE NO THOUGHTS."
IT MADE ME FEEL LIKE,
"YOU'RE REALLY MESSING UP."
>> THAT'S YOUR MOMENT
TO START THINKING OF SOMETHING.
LOOK, DON'T TAKE EVERYTHING
TO BRING YOU DOWN.
EVERYTHING, YOU KNOW,
WHEN PEOPLE GIVE YOU
A BIT OF A CRITIQUE,
IT'S OFTEN TO PICK YOU UP.
SO TAKE IT AND USE IT.
>> OKAY. THANK YOU.
UP NEXT IS MIKAELA AND SARA.
COME ON DOWN.
>> FOR ME, MIKAELA,
YOU LOOK BEAUTIFUL,
YOU HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY BONE STRUCTURE,
BUT BEING ON THE SHOOT
AND KNOWING
WHAT WE WENT THROUGH,
I MEAN, YOUR EYES WEREN'T OPEN
IN ANY PICTURES.
>> SMACK THE PHOTOGRAPHER
UPSIDE HIS HEAD,
THROUGH THAT LENS,
WITH YOUR EYES.
>> SARA MISSES THE MOMENT.
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE JUST
GOT CAUGHT ON CAMERA
AT THE PARTY.
>> IT'S OKAY FOR ME.
IT'S NOT BRILLIANT.
I'VE L-LOST YOUR COOL CHICNESS,
YOUR DIFFERENTNESS,
YOUR--YOUR MODERNITY.
THIS SHOT JUST DOESN'T WORK.
I LOVE YOU RIGHT NOW, THOUGH.
>> THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PLANES OF YOUR FACE
THAT THE CAMERA LOVES,
AND YOU--YOU NEED TO KNOW THIS
AND OWN WHAT YOU HAVE.
OKAY, THANK YOU, LADIES.
>> THANK YOU.
>> KASIA AND MOLLY.
NOW, MOLLY, YOUR WEAVE IS
LOOKING A LITTLE CRAZY.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE
UNDERNEATH THIS?
>> YEAH.
>> IT'S A WEAVE MALFUNCTION
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH.
>> SOMETIMES THINGS
GO A LITTLE BIT AWRY.
>> MM-HMM.
>> AND, UH, WE'LL--
WE'LL HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT
IF YOU STICK AROUND.
OKAY, HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
>> OOH, MY GOODNESS.
MOLLY, WOW.
IT'S STRIKING.
SUPERCOOL. SUPER--
I MEAN, KASIA,
I'M NOT 100% SURE
ABOUT THIS SHOT WITH YOU,
THE MOUTH OPEN THAT MUCH,
SO DARK IN THERE.
LOOKS A LITTLE UN--
IT JUST LOOKS WEIRD.
>> OH, STOP HATIN'.
>> IT--I MEAN, SHE LOOK--
>> THAT MOUTH OPEN IS STUNNING.
>> I'M NOT SURE HERE.
>> I LOVE THE PHOTO.
I THINK IT'S THE BEST
OF THE WHOLE THING.
MOLLY, YOU LOOK LIKE
THE STRONG WARRIOR SISTER,
AND, KASIA, YOU LOOK LIKE
THE UPTOWN SISTER,
THE GOOD GIRL.
IF YOU TRIED TO UPSTAGE
EACH OTHER, IT DIDN'T WORK,
BECAUSE YOU BOTH LOOK GREAT.
>> THAT'S FUNNY.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPH,
TOO.
>> WELL, OF COURSE, DARLING.
>> YES, BABY.
I MEAN, THIS WAS A MOMENT.
YOU KNOW,
WE WERE SHOOTING COUTURE,
YOU'RE IN
YOUR OSCAR DE LA RENTA GOWN,
IN THIS FUN, LIKE,
VINTAGE SAINT LAURENT
WITH THIS KOOKY DRESS OVER IT.
YOU BOTH WERE INDIVIDUALS.
>> MOLLY, I LOVE THAT YOU'RE
JUST A LITTLE BAD RASCAL
THAT'S JEALOUS
OF YOUR LITTLE SISTER
THAT'S THE FAVORITE.
YOU KNOW, "SCREW THAT."
>> THE REBEL.
>> SHE'S THE REBEL.
>> YEAH, YOU GUYS BOTH SHINE.
>> (mouths word)
>> THANK YOU.
IT'S TIME FOR THE JUDGES
TO DELIBERATE,
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE
OF YOU IS GOING HOME.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> NOW I DO BELIEVE IT IS TIME
TO START OUR DÉLIBÉRATION.
>> MM-HMM.
>> THE FIRST GROUP--
MONIQUE AND ALEXANDRIA.
>> UM, I THINK MONIQUE
HAS THAT VERY OLD-SCHOOL,
DREAMY QUALITY TO HER.
>> BUT ALEXANDRIA WORKS IT.
SHE PULLS INTOTHE CAMERA.
>> SHE NAILED IT.
I MEAN, ALEXANDRIA IN THIS SHOT,
FOR ME,
IS THE ONE I'M LOOKING AT.
BUT THE FACT THAT YOU TOLD ME
THAT SHE WAS FUSSY AND FIDGETY
AND POTENTIALLY BOTHERSOME,
YOU KNOW, IS A PROBLEM.
>> HANNAH AND BRITTANI.
>> THIS IS A GORGEOUS PICTURE.
BOTH OF THEM STAND OUT FOR ME
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH.
>> THEY DO BALANCE EACH OTHER
OUT VERY NICELY.
FOR ME, HANNAH HAS JUST
COME ALIVE IN THIS SHOT.
HER BODY LANGUAGE IS FANTASTIC.
>> I MEAN, THE MAKEOVER
ON BRITTANI, LIKE, BLEW MY MIND.
SHE BECAME A LITTLE STAR.
>> I THINK BRITTANI IS,
LIKE, A DREAM.
DALYA, JACLYN, AND DOMINIQUE.
>> THIS IS
THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY PICTURE
OF JACLYN.
IT'S DREAMY, IT'S ETHEREAL,
IT'S SOUTHERN BELLE,
IT'S "GONE WITH THE WIND."
I THINK DALYA'S DONE
A GOOD JOB, TOO,
BUT THE HAND TO THE FACE IS
A LITTLE MODELING 101.
>> DOMINIQUE IS OBVIOUSLY
PROBLEMATIC IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH
BECAUSE NO MODEL CAN SAY TO--
THEY ARE THINKING OF NOTHING.
>> SHE--SHE'S NOT
THE BRIGHTEST SPARK, IS SHE?
>> DO YOU THINK
SHE'S OVERWHELMED? YES?
>> YES.
>> MIKAELA AND SARA.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE CONTROL
OVER YOUR BEAUTY,
AND MIKAELA WAS SO AWKWARD
IN HER FACE
AND FINDING THAT CAMERA
AND WHAT TO DO.
I MEAN, HER EYES WERE NOT OPEN
IN ANY PHOTOGRAPH.
>> WELL, SARA--I DON'T FEEL
THE IMPACT OF BEAUTY HERE
IN SARA.
>> I JUST THINK, FOR ME,
THAT SHE'S BETTER THAN THIS.
I THINK SHE COULD ACTUALLY DO--
BE STRONGER THAN THIS.
>> SARA DEFINITELY HAS TO WORK
ON, YOU KNOW, THAT FACE.
I THINK SARA DOESN'T KNOW
HER POTENTIAL.
>> KASIA AND MOLLY.
>> I THINK IT'S STUNNING.
IT ALL COMES TOGETHER.
I LOVE THE LIGHT IN THE TREES
POPPING THROUGH.
UH, MOLLY, UH, OOH.
>> I MEAN,
MOLLY IS JUST FABULOUS.
SHE JUST GOT IT.
SHE WENT IN THERE,
TOTALLY EFFORTLESS,
BUT TOTALLY AWARE
OF WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
AND I MEAN, THAT IS REALLY
THE COMBINATION
OF A GREAT MODEL.
>> SWANS.
FIRST KASIA HAS STRETCHED
HER NECK LIKE THE SWAN...
>> MM.
>> WHICH IS ONE
OF THE MOST FABULOUS
ICONIC MOMENTS.
AND BOTH KASIA AND MOLLY HAVE
TAKEN US TO THE LEVEL
OF SWANDOM. SWANDOM.
>> LOVE A SWANDOM.
>> YEAH, A SWANDOM.
>> WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
>> WE HAVE REACHED A DECISION.
♪♪♪♪♪
>> 11 BEAUTIFUL GIRLS
STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE TEN PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE GIRLS THAT ARE
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GONNA CALL IS
BEST PICTURE.
ALEXANDRIA.
SO YOU STAND BEFORE ME
BECAUSE YOU WON THE TASK,
WHICH WAS TO STAND OUT
MORE THAN ANYONE.
WELL, WHAT ALSO STANDS OUT IS
A BAD ATTITUDE ON SET,
AND THAT WON'T BE TOLERATED.
>> NO, IT WON'T.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
RUNNER-UP FOR BEST PHOTO...
MOLLY.
BAD WEAVE AND ALL.
SEE?
AND WE'RE GONNA REDO THIS WEAVE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
BRITTANI.
KASIA.
(imitates French accent) JACLYN!
(normal voice) JACLYN.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
HANNAH.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL
IS...
MONIQUE.
YOU'RE SHOCKED
'CAUSE YOU CAN DO BETTER.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> THE NEXT NAME...
DALYA.
>> (sniffles)
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> THANK YOU, TYRA.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
THE NEXT NAME I'M GONNA CALL
IS...
MIKAELA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
WILL DOMINIQUE AND SARA
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
>> IT'S INTERESTING
THAT THE TWO QUIRKY, ODD,
NONSTEREOTYPICAL BEAUTIES
STAND BEFORE ME.
BUT I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL THAT IS
STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL ONLY CALL ONE NAME,
AND THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY PACK YOUR BAGS
AND GO HOME.
SO, SARA,
THE JUDGES THINK YOU HAVE
SUCH POTENTIAL.
BUT, SARA,
YOU LACK THE CONFIDENCE,
AND WE'RE NOT SURE
IF YOU BELIEVEIN YOURSELF,
THAT YOU CANBE AMAZING.
AND THEN WE HAVE DOMINIQUE.
AGAIN,
ANOTHER INTERESTING, ODD BEAUTY,
BUT FRECKLES DON'T MAKE
THE MODEL.
IT COMES FROM THE INSIDE OUT.
SO...
WHO STAYS IN THIS COMPETITION?
>> SARA.
>> (sniffles)
>> SO TELL ME,
WHAT'S THIS DOUBT THAT YOU HAVE?
WHAT IS IT?
>> I'M JUST GONNA HAVE TO
LOOK INSIDE
AND TRY AND FIGURE OUT
WHERE IT COMES FROM
AND HOW TO DEAL WITH IT.
>> YEAH. CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
>> THANK YOU.
>> GIVE ME A HUG.
SO YOU--YOU'VE KIND OF
WALKED AWAY FROM
THIS COMPETITION A LITTLE BIT.
DO YOU THINK YOU'RE GONNA
WALK OUT OF THESE DOORS
AND--AND GIVE UP
AND DO SOMETHING ELSE?
>> I'M GONNA GO TO EVERY AGENCY
THAT I CAN THINK OF.
YOU NEED TO BRING
THE FABULOUS FASHION TO THEM,
NOT THE "I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T HAVE AN INSPIRATION
IN MY HEAD."
SO PRACTICE
IN THAT MIRROR FIRST
BEFORE YOU STEP INTO
ANY MODELING AGENCY, OKAY?
>> OKAY.
>> THANK YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> I HAVE A GREAT PERSONALITY,
AND IT JUST DIDN'T SHOW.
I'M GONNA CONTINUE
PURSUING MODELING.
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME EVER
TRYING TO DO SUCH A THING,
AND I FEEL THAT I WILL
BE A GREAT ASSET
TO THIS INDUSTRY.
Captioned by
Closed Captioning Services, Inc.